my children as i told you we these shows
are on all throughout the house and i
see him invariably
as a guest judge on the masked singer
or on ken jong's offshoot of i can see
your voice
now my kids are like dad we gotta we
gotta make sure
that we are ready for the masked dancer
okay and the host of that show
um which premieres on sunday after the
nfl on fox
uh is none other than craig robinson
here on the rich eisen show how are you
craig
hey how you doing rich pleasure talking
to you sir
a pleasure likewise shout out to your
family man your kids oh
craig you have no idea i am getting
considerable daddy points
just merely talking to you right now
crap
right on oh my gosh so
is this essentially basically a bunch of
famous people
masking up similar with the big heads
the big big
outfits and just dancing what what is
this going to be here what do we have
here that is exactly what it is
okay except for the you know they have
choreographed dances and they have other
dances around them
so it's actually quite entertaining okay
everybody's not you know
an astute uh fred astaire type uh
uh or for you younger kids
everybody's not a great dancer but uh
you know
it's different levels than uh and it's
it's a lot of fun
okay it's i didn't know how they were
going to do it with with the dancing
and people even ask me you know how were
you supposed to tell somebody
dancing but the singing is a whole
different story right
but dancing you know it's the whole big
uh
and so they're they're and then they're
gonna just you know uh disguise the
voices too
like it's the same it's the same thing
it's just instead of singing it's
dancing that's basically what we got
here exactly right except for there's
some extra clues in the crew package
okay there's clues in the way that
people dance you know
uh um and there's also
for when they do when they ask them
questions yes
there's a game we play called word up
okay where they get
one word the person says one word when
their real voice
so you get to hear the real voice and
also the word that they say is a clue
so it's clues all over the place so it
makes it fun
and challenging all right who are the
judges saying is it similar
who do we got as the judges craig the
only only uh
only similar overlap is uh ken jong of
course
of course everywhere he's
everywhere he's everywhere that's his
night oh my god like
three shows or whatever so uh yeah i
mean because it's funny
uh craig we had joel mchale on the show
recently and
you know um my kids again they can't get
enough of ken jong my children can't get
enough of ken jong
so well john connects with the children
that's what everybody tells me about
their kids my kids love kids
so uh [ __ ] obviously is in tune with
that
speaking of joel mchale yes joel and ken
are hosting uh
new year's eve on fox and i will i will
be with my band we'll be like the house
band
so check that out but uh to finish the
question let me just
say uh yes the rest of the judges are
brian austin green
okay uh ashley tisdale okay
queen paula abdul oh okay
so that she's kind of like a legacy for
shows like this in a way on fox all
right so
um exactly i gotcha and brian austin
green uh i believe
was a masked singer spoiler alert um
and so uh i will again ask you the same
question asked joel mchale
uh craig my children are 12 nine and
seven
at what point do i show them ken jong
hopping out of the back of the car in
the hangover
at what point do i tell them about it
what do i do
i would i would say uh it's a 12 year
old a boy or girl
it's a boy okay so so in three years
he can watch something gotta wait
i don't even have the heart to tell him
you know what i mean like it's it
it happened you know what i mean i just
can't even tell them
you know hey rich yeah craig like let me
let me give you
watch this video called what's it gonna
be with
ken jong okay okay you're gonna get to
see a whole
whole other side of the bill what's not
not
not hangover but it's uh it's fun it's
funny
but it is a risque song
[Music]
all right we'll just make sure that the
uh the youtube filters are on
uh prior to me checking that one out um
okay very very good do that okay very
very good
uh and what when is it appropriate to
show them the hot tub time machine
craig what do you think about that one
that's gonna have to be a college
graduation gift
[Laughter]
i've got craig robinson here on the rich
hissing show okay so you're a south
sider correct
you're south starter from the great city
of chicago is that correct that's
correct sir
okay you're a 49 year old man so i
imagine the the last dance that was on
in uh
uh during the spring about the jordan
years that speaks to you
i imagine that that was must-see viewing
i i haven't
made an appointment to watch something
on television and i don't know how long
right but that was yeah absolutely must
be viewing we
we uh and it was mid pandemic you know
right right in the pandemic so
right we were meeting my buddy's house
in social distance
uh it was it was the weirdest funnest
time
i mean what about just that that team
just
going through it and you know obviously
knowing what the bulls were
and what they have since become and what
they are
that is just the i mean what a run that
is one of the greatest
sports teams of of all time did you go
to uh any
any games at the old uh um well
obviously united center but obviously
chicago stadium
did you attend any of those games what a
gut check
to find out that they had another year
they could have been together
i know what a slam of the gut that was
like
what um i did i went to
one game at um at madison
square i'm sorry what's it called in the
old
chicago stadium yeah in the old chicago
stadium man i went to one game and i
the exact game it was jordan just they
were playing the hulk
but spud webb was the current duck
champion jordan was coming back it was
the first game back from his uh
i think he had broke his foot or
something he was a foot injury
whatever he did with his foot his first
came back
and uh i remember spud webb again
current dunk champion
got a fast break and i mean we were all
just like
a baited breath and he laid it up
and uh yeah i remember that oh my gosh
that was before obviously all the
championship years i mean that was at
the very birth of all of it
um and so what about your game uh craig
do you have any
any any basketball game because uh i'm
i'm kind of
leading towards uh one of my favorite
scenes in the history of the office
which was the pickup basketball game on
the loading dock
uh hey i i re i watched a scene
uh i think a 10-minute scene of that
recently and uh i forgot i hit that
that long jumper off the backboard
it was a line drive but i hit it baby so
that was it that was for real that
wasn't planned that was just like teed
up let it fly craig robinson and then
just like okay we'll keep that
is that how that works bro that's
exactly what we were just playing
that's what made it even more fun no way
really
yeah seriously like walk me through that
scene walk me through the scene craig
seriously
start to finish here one of the things
that first of all
did they show the part they showed when
steve uh or michael scott threw the ball
all the way
down the court you hit right that
happened
um uh there was one thing where i was
supposed to
make the shot and then come and uh
me and patrice o'neil give each other
like a celebratory cool handshake
so i missed the jumper twice you know i
did i just laid it in
i did that but uh yeah it was all just
playing back and forth man just uh
and getting whatever they could you
can't tell me though that
leslie david baker who played stanley
really dribbles like that though right
did that was uh what's that what do you
think pretty sure that's how he dribbles
no
come on no no no that had to be like
let's figure out a way for stanley to
dribble like that that
are you serious that's how he dribbles i
uh you know
that's that's all i remember i don't
remember him ever
holding the ball and actually dribbling
correctly
so that's all i ever saw he might have
been adding some to it with
putting his hand behind his back one of
the greatest handles of all time
one of the greatest handles of all time
in my day i was more of a rebounder okay
take it back
up strong okay you're uh you're more of
an oakley guy is what you're saying to
go real old-school here
you want you're more of an oakley guy
and you didn't have your handle
oh my gosh that was just i i'm just
wondering
where they just came up with the idea of
like let's have a pickup basketball game
and let's just do it that had to be that
that's incredible
i mean i can just imagine what the uh
what the writers will be doing today can
you imagine a
a zoom office meeting
us working from home oh my god can you
imagine what
what would creed's background be in his
house
it'd be like he accidentally see the uh
the dexter table or whatever it is
[Laughter]
which which character would forget that
they left the camera on and they thought
the camera's off which one would that be
green
meredith is there with topless
or pulling a jeffrey toobin who knows
what's going on
[Laughter]
i think we've just come up with
something craig i got to be honest with
you at least for charity
you know what i mean i think we just
came up with something here i
you know and it'll be different than
that than the you know the table reads
a lot of people doing these taberies
right we could actually do an episode
like a new one an office zoom um dunder
mifflin zoom
meeting oh my god i think we just
stumbled on something because you'd do
it right
you for charity you'd do it of course
you do i would i would do it
in a heartbeat i mean what do you think
of when you watch these episodes back
i'm sure you've just stumbled
across them every now and then um it
just takes you
you know back down memory lane you know
it's uh
i i i don't usually watch them but then
when i like you say when i do
the other day i watch i'll probably
watch five in a row just
accidentally i was in atlanta and uh
just in the hotel room and
they were running on the comedy central
thing and and
next thing you know i'm just stuck
watching the office like wow this is uh
that's crazy wow it's great and it's an
honor to be a part of that you know i
look at the ones and i'm like
i've always felt like man what what in
the world how did i get on this i'm
looking at the ones i'm not on like
this is amazing this show is amazing so
yeah man i i love it and to see
that kids are you know people are like
oh yeah this is my third time watching
it all the way through
or kids are you know finding it it's
it's super dope man well i mean again
in in craig robinson here on the rich
eisen show and you're you're just
stone-faced look okay where you would
just
stare at at anybody who was saying the
most hilarious things i mean did you did
you ever break
i mean at any point in time yeah
there was there was some breakage for
sure they're breakage but uh
that that's one of the things about the
show that i truly love that is that uh i
got to
play deadpan because i love that kind of
humor you know the
leslie nielsen peter sellers uh harvey
korman people like that
the straight man i love that leslie
nielsen harvey corman those are great
names you just named right there craig
that's great and i would see those guys
and just
that and that's what would draw me i'm
i'm seeing that you know
how are you staying serious through all
this ridiculousness you know so uh
that's that's always been uh uh i've
been drawn to that well i mean again
we're
you i think you're 49 i'm 51 so we're of
the same age you're mentioning harvey
corman from the carol burnett show and
he would crack up all the time like he
he could not he could not
keep a straight face ever certainly like
when tim conway was doing his thing so
who is the wicked this is the wicked
exactly and there's there's a great
everyone should look up the dentist
sketch from that is a perfect example if
you want to go to youtube
so who was the one that was easiest to
crack up then from the office
oh the easiest oh god let me see let me
see
let me see who was who just couldn't
keep it together oh god i can tell you
the
oscar was the one that was hard that
that uh uh
you know he like everybody was trying to
try to get oscar
he was hard to get but um
oh you know what uh rain and uh rain and
jim
right rain uh dwight and jim they were
uh
they would they would be busting all the
time is that right
all the time yeah yeah think about like
the f
they really got to be the silliest right
especially dwight
so he would be doing these crazy things
like i remember one time
he was doing on a tightrope he was
trying to balance
and you know the tight brother just kept
going back and forth and then he
he would just crack up so we would have
to do it again but yeah yeah right
right will crack up pretty good craig
robinson here on the rich eisen show uh
the masked singer uh
after its premiere this sunday the show
is going to move to wednesdays at eight
on fox starting on
uh wednesday uh january 6th the masked
dancer i knew i would screw that up once
the mass dancer premieres this sunday
after nfl on fox and again it starts
wednesdays at 8 eastern on fox after uh
the calendar turns to 2021 on wednesday
january 6. congrats on the gig and uh i
will be there
i will be watching my kids will ca i
mean they honestly
as because i'm imagining you're right
there in uh
on a wednesday night which my kids are
used to watching uh fox for
for the mass singer and everything else
so congrats on the masked answer
all right thank you so much rich it's a
pleasure talking to you right here let's
let's stay in touch that's craig
robinson here on the rich eisen show
at mr craig robinson on both twitter
and instagram hey you watched all the
way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here